all right turning to how the U.S is
handling the migrant crisis a record
number of migrants are being apprehended
at the border Manuel bojorquez has been
reporting from a processing center in El
Paso that's where some Asylum Seekers
hope they will be among those allowed to
stay in the U.S
these are their first steps into the
United States migrants arrive here
sometimes nervous often exhausted but
hopeful so you see hope and opportunity
not only for you but for your family
that's left behind
has been traveling for a month almost a
month on the road
seven countries
a dangerous Journey from Venezuela where
he says others died along the way while
crossing through a jungle you rather
risk your life over this one month
Journey over staying in Venezuela
there's no guarantee
can't buy medicine
no education the migrants processing
happens under this bridge next to the
Border this is the initial screening and
vetting as you will where we medically
screen identify classify them this
mobile processing center is seeing an
average of 1500 migrants a day about
half of them from Venezuela how does
that change the equation for you well uh
unlike the the Mexicans and Central
Americans that we can process under the
CDC authority of title 42. we are having
to process the people coming from
Venezuela and You by Nicaragua under our
title eight authorities meaning they're
usually released and allowed to request
Asylum a process that typically takes
years to complete but not everyone is
allowed in CBP says more than 1.3
million migrants were deported or
expelled so far this year a greater
number than those still in the U.S still
critics say the Biden administration's
policies incentivized migrant Crossings
Julia Jimenez Gonzalez fled Cuba and is
hoping to reach relatives in Tampa
thank you
you want to be free and reunite with
your family a long journey with longer
still to go for CBS mornings Manuel
bojorquez El Paso Texas